everybody what is going on welcome to
another PI game tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be talking about
sounds and music with PI game so what we
want to do is add maybe some background
music to our game and then also some
sounds like especially when we crash our
car there should be like some sort of
sound that sounds like a crash so
there's a lot of places where you can
get free music either online or a like
sound effects stuff like that also
YouTube just has like an audio library
that you can use to put stuff in your
videos so I'm just going to use that but
just keep in mind you probably can't
download this and then distribute a game
with that like with this audio so just
just keep that in mind especially like
if you're charging for the game so
anyway we're just going to use this as
an example and so for music I mean we
can just like search around but
personally we would just I'm just going
to pick jazz and then I just wouldn't
head with jazz in Paris and so we get
that and then also I already have that
and then sounds I would go just typing
crash for example that's what we're
looking for and this is what we went
with was just crash right here
can't hear it very well my my sound
there we go hopefully that came through
okay so that's the other one I grabbed
now these are in mp3 format and PI game
does support mp3 as well as like OGG
sometimes but not the best the best
solution is to put it in a wav format so
if you have say any sort of moviemaker
generally also will let you convert into
mp3 wav anything like that there's
probably some sort of audio converter
too if you happen to have one also if
you just record on your desktop like a
lot of like just desktop recording
applications that come with your
computer default into WAV format I use
Sony Vegas to convert it to waves so if
you have Vegas you can use that too
anyway you can also just download some
wave formats offline so once you have
them you'll want them at least for the
purpose of this tutorial in the same
in the same directory as your script
otherwise you'll need to give the full
path we're going to assume it's in the
directory of this script which it is so
I'm not going to specify the full path
so you can basically load in these
sounds anywhere I'm going to go ahead
and load it in for right here in PI game
under this PI game in it and for example
we can load in things like crash
underscore sound and crash sound is
going to equal PI game dot mixer dot
sound and exercise capital S which is
really weird I don't understand why this
is a capital S because everything else
is on our case but sound is cats not
like music is under case I don't know
anyway sound and then we'll do this
sound is crashed out wave for me so
that's the sound file I have so now we
have this crash sound in in our memory
and then there's another one for example
if you want to do music you would do
something like uh let's just say we're
going to call this well with music
that's a little different so it sounds
you'll load in like ten different sounds
maybe for your game for music as far as
I know you you have to delight you you
cut you probably can save it to like an
object or something but for the most
part music is just one thing now you can
have like a cue of music so you could
have a different tune per level or
something like that I'm not going to get
into that now so for now we're just
going to load one thing into the music
and so that's going to be PI game mixer
music dot load and then we're gonna load
jazz dot wave anybody has an idea on why
this is specifically a capitalist but
like this isn't a capital M or this
isn't let me know I just want to know
thinking like what I'm missing from pep
8 is why we would capitalize that anyway
that loads the music but it doesn't play
it no different than this loads the
sound but it does not play it so where
do we want the crash sound to actually
occur well chances are we want that to
occur
when we actually have a crash so we'll
come down to crash and in here we would
say we want two things right we want the
the music to stop playing if it's
playing so we're going to play music in
the background but if we crash we stop
the music so we would do PI game dot
mixer music dot stop
again it's not a capitalized and then we
would want to play a PI game dot mixer
dot capital says sound dot play and then
what do we want to play we want to play
the crash sound so here we're actually
going to play it and the last thing that
we need to do is we need to go ahead and
have need to have the music playing in
our game loop so come down to the game
loop here and we need to bring in the
music bring in the music so PI game
mixer music play and then here you can
put anything like you could put like a 1
and this will play the music once and
then again once so if you put 5 it's
going to play the music 6 times and if
you put negative 1 it will play
indefinitely like it'll just keep
looping so that's what we want we just
want to loop we're not going to make it
very far anyways this game is a slow
game but each time the game loop runs
it's going to start over the music and
then when you crash it stops it which
here so it stops the music now there's
another thing that will we might want to
add and that is in pause so if we come
to our pause function when we pause the
game generally you pause because maybe
someone comes in the room and asks you a
question or the phone rings or whatever
you want to press pause and you probably
want the music still playing while
you've pressed pause so we can stop the
music or actually we can pause the music
so it doesn't start over but it pauses
it so we can do PI game mixer music dot
pause and then when we're done we need
to stop the pause right so when do we
stop the pause well whenever we call
button in the
function this button runs as unpause so
now we need to find our unpause function
which is right here and we global pause
and then we are turning it to pause
equals false well now we just do PI game
mixer music dot and it just so happens
this function is also called unpause so
that just worked out so um so that
should be it so let's go ahead and save
and run this see what we get okay so
here's our game awesome we hit go and
here comes our music wow it's really
loud
okay so we're playing I'm gonna try hit
a high score here and you crash die so
anyways you guys get the point uh you
got the music sound effects and all that
obviously you can add a lot more sound
effects you can maybe pick a better
track or something but those actually
okay an okay track for the game so
anyway um hope you guys enjoyed if you
have any questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time